mmm we are live live if you're watching
this this is the unlisted portion as
we're updating it you're watching a raw
behind-the-scenes look this is after the
video has been uploaded to YouTube as
Greg is inserting all the proper tags
and stuff to make sure people are
getting the quality content they deserve
you guys were you guys have earned it
just by being here I'm hitting Save
Changes it's been saved going to the
live control room man look out opening
this a new window yeah whoo and now and
now we go public now we go public this
is the three settings Pat hey man you
can't you can't hold us down let's see
you're able to we should be public now
all right let's get this road on the
show
can you guys who's here who's coming in
the room let's get that number to a
solid one anyone here come on peeps said
the stream service is bad of course
right well we go public it goes too bad
of course as it goes to that but hey
that's never stopped us before there's
no one here no one wants to know leader
cares a minute and a half in 640
thousand subs and no one gives a [ __ ]
no one likes they got better things to
do hey there's a first person here can
you hear us
there we go maybe it just was on a delay
you know how like every YouTube video
you said to public takes like 15 seconds
to actually get there yeah can you can
okay Oh health is good we got a stream
going got a healthy I think we finished
some healthy stream of our prostate is
is the first time in a long time we've
gone live and it's actually
working that guys we got five eyes on us
what's up oh you guys are all first
hello there people can you guys hear us
we're testing out this microphone we
need confirmation before we start
hopping into the news here look at that
people from Israel here yeah I just
watch Conan's uh Without Borders in
Israel awesome I know man okay people
are piling on in oh thank you guys so
much for being here let's wait till we
got at least a hundred eyes on us we got
Texas in the house upstate New York the
UK I have so many movie news things book
Mart Belgium and we're gonna we're gonna
be able to go through a lot of these
it's Monday and 2000 Monday is a day
where I'm Lee Sharpe sunday is the day
I'm Lee Sharpe Monday is the working day
I'm Lee sure
sunday is reset my life day and and this
is where yeah so some real news Tyrone
Magnus and scar tissue whoever scarce
Carlos car show Tyrone put up a video
today saying that they're dating now
scourge oh yeah whatever her name is
okay alright you guys know her name scar
low whatever okay let's talk about oil
news for those who are here
Greg will never throw out that shirt hey
this Lydia person I'm gonna put show you
can go [ __ ] yourself you flus ER they
commented um on our community page
you suck I'm like what are you doing our
community page you know it goes you
clearly have nothing to do with your
life so you just spend time here on the
internet you [ __ ] loser thanks for
informing me that I'd rather be here
doing this than wasting my life like you
you could think we suck but at least
we're doing alright on our end
I don't usually find people and just
tell them uh ah gosh like a waste of
energy like Thank You Britney for that a
super chat by the way John what were you
saying oh no just go find a free
that you actually like and tell them
that they're great and you will use that
energy for something so much more
meaningful yeah or something that you
like like what gives yeah no yeah yeah
she really got to me and I'm gonna keep
it there you know she can go [ __ ]
yourself
[Laughter]
it's one thing to leave a comment on a
YouTube you go or a community page it's
like what are you doing here anyway
thanks often it don't worry guys anyone
who does a super chat we will
acknowledge your questions we have a
window open right here we'll hop back
and forth between the movie news we have
bookmark and also the super chat that we
got going on let's hop right into this
now that were 5 minutes in guys Ryan
John I don't know what some of this news
came out yesterday and in some countries
that's April Fool's Day okay already
and then today it's for California
Pacific Standard Time it is April Fool's
Day so some of these movie news things
I'm like is this one real but this one
came out today ryan johnson will direct
the first of the Star Wars trilogy from
the showrunners of the Old Republic
trilogy from the guys who Shepherd Game
of Thrones yeah which I think if this is
real I cannot wait for the backlash I am
so excited for yeah especially now I'm
sitting here going are these two
trilogies really one trilogy all along
that they've been teasing us about or is
this yeah some kind of elaborate April
Fool yeah I mean what do you guys think
of this news do you think it's actually
real for ryan johnson to be doing this
it sounds a little bit ridiculous to me
that the first one because they said
that it was gonna be the you know he was
gonna have his own trilogy and now
they're saying he's gonna direct the
first of theirs I'm like this has to be
fake right this just has to be fake I
can't imagine this is real I feel like
it's a good fake just because I'm like I
don't know what capacity Benioff and
wise want to be involved with this and
they've got
Game of Thrones spin-offs to worry about
like maybe they don't want to direct
this maybe they just want to be the
creative producers and be the Kevin
braggy of the Old Republic or whatever
but it is it's just weird to me to hear
that and yeah especially after like
we're giving Ryan Johnson his own
trilogy and then after the backlash
they're like we're keeping his trilogy
the backlash amuses me guys
really knows Brittney laying her super
chat question thank you so much my dear
what are you guys's thoughts uh of the
average of the Avenger of admits but
Avengers end game running time for three
hours in two minutes
oh hello from Vancouver Canada what's up
Canada what it do these sons of B words
apparently they shoot supernatural up
there so good good on y'all uh yeah we
did a whole video talking about the
runtime and the new not to make your
super try to waste here Britney Hugh but
we did a whole video about it where you
know we're talking about the runtime and
and for John and I we're both not
bothered by the Avengers engine runtime
I expected this to be quite honest I was
the second half to something that was
already like two and a half good hours
like I gotta imagine it has to be a
little bit thicker even so to wrap up
whatever they got a wrap up characters
we know might not come back like you
know send offs and all that I'm not
surprised I mean three hours and two
minutes to me feels kind of short
honestly i I would go if this is three
and a half hours I be I want to say I'd
be more excited it's a strange thing to
be so excited for something so long
already three at three hours and two
minutes does feel like okay this is like
you made this as compact as possible but
expect me to take at least four bathroom
breaks before the movie starts on
average if it's a movie I'm looking
forward to I pee twice before a
screening and sometimes a little bit of
extra dribble just to make sure I'm safe
and if it's gonna be three hours I'm
gonna watch the caffeine I'm gonna watch
anything it's just really a diuretic and
I'm gonna keep a low down on the fiber
so these are all like very sincere
statements I'm making right now by the
way I'm gonna be as cautious I'm gonna
see my awesome rare body oh yeah I'm
gonna be extra extra extra safe to
making sure that I do not the worst
thing is when
I have to really go to the bathroom and
it's this first time I'm watching this
I'm like I don't want this to end I mean
I what I'm thinking I'm loving this but
I want this to end so I can go to the
bathroom it's a terrible terrible
feeling to have because I just don't
want to miss a minute for me it was
Return of the King but thanks for the
question Brittany yeah and optimistic em
what's up we are doing a livestream
right now thank you for your super chat
buddy makes makes these worth it because
for some reason we do we these get
yellow dollar bill signs instantaneously
we can't police you know it's pretty
crazy how how much worse it is all right
so next on the movie news here the
Alexandra Shipp who play storm she was
taking a little bit of shots at the
Avengers for I'm not sure just the Adly
of x-men joining the MCU they asked her
like are you excited about this I mean
she did say like people are afraid in
this to be like she's taking shots at
the MCU she's taking shots at Marvel and
all that but I don't think that's the
case she's just expressing
dissatisfaction with the handling of a
character over time which yeah I mean
like is not a positive thing to say but
at the same time I think she has a point
it's like yeah the most memorable storm
line from any of the x-men movies is do
you know what happens to a toad when it
gets struck by lightning you know which
is unfortunate but she was saying how
the exact quote here is no I because it
was specifically in regards to should
she be with if she if storm goes into
the MCU you know getting her with black
panther because in the comics they get
married no I don't think storm means a
chawla and I think she needs her own
movie it doesn't have to be me it just
needs to be made good follow up line a
woman does not need a man in order to
give her validity and she has been
around longer than him I mean as two men
would we agree with that Jon just know
what lady's near everything to you all
the ladies in the in the chat right now
come on you know you need us know you
need us in order to survive yeah right
we we are the Queen's you at all this is
this is crazy talk what you speaking at
birth to you guys
right I mean even in Kill Bill we're
only pretty much the people who died
were at the hands of women mm-hmm she
was still all about Bill Nye I'm cool
I'm cool with her other sentiments yeah
that's true I don't think it's bad if
they get married personally or they do
start I think what she's ultimately
implying especially as you read on
further because she was saying that
she's excited for all this she is I
think what she's just mainly implying is
let's storm be very much established
first as her own standalone iconic
character on the big screen in the films
like sure in the comics she is but in
that let's face it then all the
interpretations we've got him in the
live-action she's kind of just like
background character overall one that's
that was yeah I mean then she goes on to
basically express her dismay about about
that you know yeah and I think that's a
fair point I mean she says that she I
wouldn't wouldn't like having storm you
know introduced into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because storm has
barely barely has anything to say as it
is I don't know about you all other
actors but like we never talked so it
would be really nice if we weren't piled
into yet another jam-packed cast in
which you only see me in the back of a
shot like a friggin sasquatch I mean I
feel like at the end of the day no
matter what happens no matter what
happens with an x-men character it's
very hard to make a push for a
standalone film most of the time if
they're part of the x-men universe
because anytime you push for a
standalone film if that's what they get
first especially it's just gonna be met
with a barrage of comments and fan
outcry for I want them to be part of the
X that's the way it goes you know yeah
what would be smarter x-men over time is
I guess you know have your one or two
central characters but make sure that
each time you shuffle in a couple
different ones and give them prominent
important roles you know because I do
agree with her it's like storm is one of
the most iconic x-men and she's barely
left an impression on me in any of the
movies other than like her casting yeah
you know like you're like Halle Berry
exactly
hey red Ville thanks for the super chat
my homie yeah it's I think it's red
Ville red nine eight eight
I am tree can you guys react to the dead
don't die trailer Bill Murray Adam Jim
Jarmusch yeah that would we were
actually going to and then I was doing
some research I feel like forever is
here the hundred twenty something eyes
we have on us right now
you guys might have heard Tyrone Magnus
talking a lot about this lately in terms
of YouTube copyright content includes
copyright content or videos getting
blocked worldwide and yeah in the past
couple months especially we have been
hit with a large large amount of that
every day there's a new one from like on
this video is like two years old you
know especially with music companies
they're getting just so much more strict
about this so read I have to inform you
that looking up the distribution company
that video has a pretty high the reason
we didn't cover it this morning is
because it has a pretty good chance of
getting blocked worldwide almost
instantaneously now it's a real bummer
and that's the main reason why we're not
going to cover it is because of that
fact and it's like a lot of times where
these meet with the music especially and
a lot of these videos and the trailers
they use a lot of like popular songs
more than just original songs made for
the movie but even then like our
avengers endgame trailer reactions those
got demonetized
so the music companies are very much
cracking down and and the weird part is
is when it's like because the rules of
fair use are so confusing and they're
really easy to enforce or not enforce
kind of it at companies leisure so you
know if it's us versus a big music
distribution company of course they're
just going to be able to do whatever
they want yeah eventually so with the a
lot of times it could be like literally
less than 10 seconds and they'll say
block worldwide because of this portion
and it's ten seconds it's like two and
I'm like it's that fair use to include
those ten seconds especially if the
purpose of the video is to take
something in and make commentary about
it and we go
of our way to make commentary about yeah
these things so you know theoretically
it ought to be especially if the song
clip it is only like a few seconds long
or whatever like if it's a full two
minutes over a trailer I guess I
understand but on the last live stream
we did we did a live reaction to the
trailer good boys the red band trailer
and we didn't include the footage
because we knew that ok well based off
the company it's probably gonna get
blocked so let's do a test here we
didn't include the footage but we had
some of the we had the audio echoing off
of our speakers in the background it was
in the background and then it got the
live stream block worldwide via just
because that audio is just a trailer
audio not even showing the footage is
causing a lot of our videos to get
blocked like companies are really
cracking down on these things and you
know if it's like depending if it's like
a if Universal Pictures puts out you
know I don't know it's a big one they
have and they've they put out another
Jordan Peele trailer it's like we know
it's it's definitely not gonna be
monetized but we also know that it puts
it at risk for being blocked worldwide
but we'll try our best and we'll put it
up at least and hopes that if you have
yep the notification bail on our channel
that you'll be able to immediately at
least watch it before it gets taken off
YouTube if it's something real big we'll
try and do it if it's if it's like this
Jim Jarmusch trailer like we would love
to check it out but yeah ultimately it's
probably not going to be a time and cost
effect exactly so yeah I don't I don't
know I'm not I don't really find YouTube
is always changing and there's always
new implement there's always new ways to
make money here there's always ways your
money's getting taken away it's always
the way it's the way it goes and and
there's always something to complain
about and there's something to get
excited about so rather than doing a
bunch of videos complaining about it
here you go there it is ok this has to
be fake alright this is a movie I'm
gonna if you guys haven't seen this I'm
gonna go to the chat right now and where
to go John
pretty good no it's right here I'm gonna
go to the chat have you guys heard about
this Kevin Hart [ __ ] and as Mushu and
Mulan I'm putting this Screen Rant
article there I just put it in the chat
have you seen this yet no they're the
same first look at Kevin Hart as Mushu
mule on a remake this is via screen rat
this has to be fake and it's written by
Stephen M Colbert gotta go and check out
this photo because it's making fun of
the genie
yeah they literally just graphed his
head on and painted in red yellow they
have like lizard scales on their dragon
scales on its own I first saw it it made
me laugh is he really playing with shoes
I don't know I honestly
Mushu was a lot of Mulan was considered
to be rather racist way before you know
the 40s with Dumbo where there was some
racism and their Mulan was banned from
China I believe that it would've first
debuted because it was considered racist
I feel like if you were to do Kevin Hart
as moves you just be very racist be
great but that's just some funny if it
has to be fake right oh yeah I'll never
forget when IGN put out that fake Zelda
trailer they got everybody hyped yeah
okay so in real movie news though guys
yes yes haven't seen our Dumbo review we
know there's I see a few comments and
hear people asking about what did we
think of Dumbo yeah we didn't like it
all right long story short we really did
enjoy it Dumbo is great did the elephant
himself is great but but the movie is
right now a couple box office news you
want to talk about Dumbo
finished a number one but it's still
very much underperform people were
expecting least a sixty million dollar
debut it got 45 million ok stuff how
much CGI isn't it I imagine that to be a
flop
in other news for all you guys out there
who hate this movie and we recommended
it especially after watching a second
time Captain Marvel is less than eight
million dollars away from cracking of
billion dollars I remember being on the
camp
a show he's like I don't think this is
gonna make a billion dollars and I said
nah man it's it's definitely going to it
hell yeah I just like being right
mysticum oh thanks buddy
she really really upgrade it there
you're the best react channel now man
you it's optimism like yours that we
that we feed off of thank you so much do
that's fair that's very generous I
really appreciate that and jf not Eric
Russia's saying this channel is dope
thanks buddy you're the man you're the
man go Captain Marvel though further
faster higher higher further faster yeah
there you go I got all the words it's
just remix as much as sexist as this
maybe there's this like meme going
around of like screenshots of brie
Larson having like orgasm face as if she
was like having sex with or to the state
higher further faster that's pretty
funny you know Jabby hit a million
subscribers what when when did this
happen it's not possible no prove it
that's not true at all
that's not true at all yeah he's lying
he's lying he bought all those subs
there but he's they bought them all
don't believe him
don't believe him I'm waking up at like
5:00 a.m. to check on those endgame
tickets by the way so hopefully I'm able
to grab my we got press screening for it
but that's always a nightmare because
you got to get there like two hours
early yeah you gotta fight someone
asking me to save seats
whether it's Jabby Kawai who just hit a
million or a friend or so so frustrating
like don't count on me to save your seat
I hate saving seats especially when they
when they like confiscate your phone and
like lock it deep bowels of the earth
but I really like it when my friends say
I'm very much a hypocrite I hate saving
seats but dan and I grateful when I'm
running late very very much a hypocrite
about that okay so what else is on this
movie news that we have here that I
thought was cool Quicksilver actor Evan
Peters who I have said several times I
think it has the potential of being the
next Johnny Depp meaning he's going to
harm his
he I'm talking about in terms of young
Johnny Depp you know the good old days
of Edward Scissorhands and such if you
see we just see the wide variety of
performance he's given in stuff of
American Horror Story how he's different
in every season he has a real likeness
to young Johnny Depp and Ed rain
apparently and this one up today so I
don't know if this is real he was doing
an interview somewhere he didn't say I'm
playing Wolverine but he was it was that
WonderCon which by the way I was I want
to come this weekend he was saying that
I you wouldn't mind playing Wolverine in
the future I like he's thinking about
this always well great a hundred percent
dude can rejuvenate like he'd love to
play this guy I personally think it'd be
insanely distracting for him to play
Wolverine yeah I think it would be
pretty confusing it's one thing for
Chris Evans to go from a fox produced
Fantastic Four movie that had nothing to
do with the MCU and then hop to a very
different Marvel property within the MCU
for Fantastic Four to Captain America
but to go from the x-men universe and
then go into a different character and
someone at such as iconic as well brain
and he really made a staple for himself
as Quicksilver out of as much as I adore
Evan Peters the actor I would I would be
very weary about this maneuver yeah I
just think it would be distracting
ultimately even if he does buff up and
redo his hair I mean I don't doubt that
he's got the acting chops but I feel
like we just live on the wrong timeline
for this yeah I feel like you need an
unknown to be Wolverine or something or
somebody left center in Rahzel but Tom
Hardy there you go sharlto copley yeah
actually work plus if he like really
buffed up and kind of changed his
physicality a little bit like I think
that would be yeah that would be cool
get a disney on the horn can't wait
can't wait for it so that's that one
right no Scott Eastwood for Wolverine I
do not accept that
and you know I've seen a lot of comments
about this post about this one star to
us and it was one of my bookmark stories
here so I'll just hop right to this
since you guys are talking about the
chat mark hamill is going to be the new
voice of Chuckie in the childsplay
reboot to me I like I know Brad Dourif
has the very iconic voice associated
with child's play
it's and Mark Hamill is a wonderful
voice actor an amazing voice and not
terms of like oh he just lends it like
who's the guy who do does hey he's got
plays Joe Swanson
Oh Patrick Warburton they always ring
Patrick Warburton to play
Patrick warburg or H John Benjamin is
always H junbae exactly yeah the guy
plays Archer yeah he's there always
brought in to do their voice yeah
whereas Mark Hamill he can do voices
like him West everyone knows like him as
the Joker some people claim that's the
best Joker right there and that he's
menacing in that voice and has a lot of
fun and just honestly even though the
main association for voice-over work
that Mark Hamill has done comes in the
form of the Joker that's enough for me
to go oh okay I'm excited about this
because that wide range of Menace terror
humor that's what Chucky is required to
do like that those qualities are what's
required for Chucky so I think Mark
Hamill would be a wonderful out of any
known actor so I could think of who
could do it I can't see a better fit
than Mark Hamill yeah this is I mean not
to this is a bad metaphor because I
really didn't like this movie but it was
like when they replaced Jack hero of
Robert Englund with Jackie Earle Haley I
was like okay this is about the one time
I could imagine this maybe working out
and and yeah I'm right there with you
harness like as much as Brad like the
thing I'm wondering is how different
because I know Mark Hamill has a lot of
that gruffness in his voice that is kind
of similar to Brad Dourif
in general so I'm wondering just how
he's gonna approach it you know if he's
gonna go more high-pitched if he's gonna
keep some of that rasp or what but yeah
about the only name I could hear and go
okay
sure Jenna Randolph thank you so much
for the super chat my dear sorry for the
late patreon payment and if I message
too much now you know you're just fine
patreon charge me with a listen I'm glad
your arms doing better do sir if you're
already a patron here and and if you
contribute to the super chat we really
appreciate it
would you've done plenty you don't have
to do that okay like don't get me wrong
I love money I did too it helps a lot I
put money I hate money but health floss
friends maybe family no no money food
friends family that's the order I put it
in so I love money
Jeeter what's up dog if it's up gene oh
yeah we got some patient's up in his
house thank you so much
Jenna I've really appreciate it thank
you so much I mean we'll take it we're
not gonna refund I really want to
contribute more good but I'm just gonna
say the humbling stuff to make us look
good
I'm just hoping that at the beginning of
the new child's play they subvert our
expectations by having Mark Hamill look
at a knife really quick and throw it
over his shoulder and just see like the
good guys must end you know or something
like that you know and get get some
different [ __ ] happening if you guys
haven't seen this yet I'm gonna put this
in the chat right now look out look out
when toys are spoilers or sock Thanos
and use people there and game Legos out
now to Santos news okay so the new toy
line has revealed that OSes new weapon
and it's weird how toy companies can
sometimes be a great spoiler mm-hmm
like they revealed the the white suits
way before the trailer did okay and I
rarely follow toy news and I just happen
to stumble across this that's where I
get all my movie news he has this double
bladed sword here I just put it in the
chat you guys haven't seen it yet it's a
pretty bitchin weapon honestly I still
use the word bitchin I think it's a
really Thai weapon and it looks really
radical on him as well yeah one and I
guess this
the gauntlet is not busted either yeah
there's the thing Goins busted Commons
busted but now the gauntlets Lulu seems
like he maybe use the stones to fix the
gauntlet yeah well he has the power to
wipe out half the universe I'm sure you
figured out a way to fix the Goblin
there so there you got that there and
then also this double-edged sword does
he really need the sword if he's got the
gauntlet yeah I guess he wouldn't need
the sword unless they're misleading us
somehow you know the thing that gets in
the way of Fano is being able to quickly
beat people at a much faster rate is him
at times willing to be respectful and
like really respect the art of the
battle and the character he's going up
against when really he could just snap
them away if you wants to yeah yeah sit
away from me get him no never you guys I
don't get why you keep coming at me so I
mean cool toy that's about it I wonder
if you'll need to use the sword you know
yeah maybe maybe he's opening packages
or something maybe it's a box cutter
okay so this got me excited you know
Harley Quinn and the Joker break up in
you birds of prey cephus it is it this
way I love the video real or fake news
alright first off John and I do have a
you know a conspiracy theory belief that
studios might be leaking set photos now
because it's really hard to cover up
sometimes like maybe they fabricate set
photos as well the other thing is this
joker new birds of prey set photos here
I'll put this in the this and in there
as well for you guys if you haven't seen
it basically in these photos which you
see is clearly the Joker and she's like
what it looks like she's headed climbing
out the window or they're breaking up or
someone that's at least what the photos
are hinting at there's gonna be a moment
where she's breaking up with him and
he's clearly designed as Jared Leto's
Joker but you can't see his face
basically the window the the board part
where he like shut the window at the
bottom is covering up where his face
would go but the whole design is very
much JLo Joker he's got this slicked
back green hair and yeah he looks kind
of wiry
got a big old puffy shirt on and I don't
know if they actually got she I can't
add this would be a spoiler first sort
of movie coming up all right there I
don't know if they got the actual Jared
Leto to show up for this or they just
gotten someone a stand-in be a double
and we're not actually gonna show his
face or hear his voice even you just get
this brief moment where you already have
like Harley Quinn and then breaking up
and you just see the Joker kind of in
the background but you don't actually
see the Joker
that's more and I imagine that's
probably what we're gonna see I guess so
I mean I'm because of the confusion of
the DC with the Joker movie a walking
Phoenix so if they be playing it safe
that way like I I don't want to spoil
some things that are that I already know
about that one specifically is where
where I'm getting a big hint do you know
what I'm talking about no idea what
you're talking about
oh that okay yeah then that's kind of
what gave me that idea it's just okay I
gotta wait for this movie to come out
but I can't spoil it is a yeah I guess
I'm just staring at this photo going how
are we drawing so much context out of
just an image where it seems like she's
leaving a house like do we know this is
a breakup like why are we why are we how
do we know it's the break okay doesn't
matter what it is alright even if it's a
breakup or not I'm saying the point of
the scene to have the Joker there oh
yeah I don't think it we're gonna
actually see Jared Leto as the Joker be
wrong but that was my theory this is not
a double in there certainly suggests
that yeah the way his face is just
directly obscured by the bottom half of
the window that's basically what I'm
getting is going to you with that
thought yeah I would I wouldn't be
surprised by that at all Harry earth
thanks so much for uh the super chat
there buddy
thoughts on ant-man and fan knows
[ __ ] a-hole I hope they thought about
the idea that you know an man could just
climb into that OSes anus and then
expand and like rip him apart from the
inside and or you know go inside of his
anus and just wreak general havoc on the
inside of his body like there's so many
possibilities related to ant-man
shrinking down and going up Thanos
and it's become a very popular topic on
the Internet why because I know how to
work yeah yeah what did that work it
would work that's the problem
it's a major plot just do that plot
holes in the ass holes yeah you know
usually in the ultimate mole I mean that
would be the boldest thing any superhero
movie up until this point is ever done
is if they did like an ass blast that
would be a great way to actually cap it
off mm-hmm yeah Harry I'm not I'm not
opposed to that mmm almost as a Mudge
and the Mandarin twist was funny too
all right just a couple more movie news
then we're gonna call this a day denis
villeneuve this has okay I'm thinking
this is fake - this feels phases the
seals face - means via Screen Rant
deneva the new Nina Nina is directing
Cloverfield for after dude what's funny
about this fake news story which I'm
assuming is fake what is that it's the
one that could be Fatima be real because
of the existence of 10 Cloverfield Lane
I'm like maybe yeah what happens a great
idea that's like kind of simple but
really cinematic but I think after a
Cloverfield 3 this franchise is done
like no one liked that movie
I mean her dachshund we thought it was
all right for the first half I liked
what it wanted to be a lot more than
what it was like but it was pretty
pretty awful and that was the general
response the reason they dropped it on
Netflix the way they did yeah I just
don't like you're gonna get to need to
do it like you're gonna you that's gonna
be a feat or release and maybe they
could get more eyes on frankly like if
you didn't see it might be pretty cool
honestly it just sounds super fake to me
you know yeah I mean yeah way different
caliber of a director than I would ever
expect you know unless they take dune
and just make Doudna Cloverfield sequel
because why not and then this one right
here Marvel this came out today and this
doesn't seem like it be fake to me
I feel like this could be very real I
can't imagine what why you who you're
trying to Punk by faking this yeah
because there's nothing specific as to
who she be playing but famous superstar
international star criança Chopra like I
call her Chopra
I think it's Chopra Slap Chop I think
it's Jonas Brothers wife yes all of it
always married all them they're freaky
family those Jonases she she apparently
she's in talks to be in a upcoming
Marvel film which I'm sure it gets fans
excited especially you know for the
people who come here from the chamuco a
channel after you guys are very much
excited for this I simmer down
excitement because we're constantly
hearing of actors we love and adore and
respect especially in a night you know
you're a gem a chance gonna be in
Captain Mart we we hear about it all the
time and then that's always usually nine
times out of ten it's a lackluster role
well yeah because they're just here like
they never really get to be characters
beyond just like ah you got a cool look
and occasionally you do one cool action
thing and then you have like a joke and
collectors ever that memorable
they don't really serve much importance
they're kind of just there and it gets
people excited in terms of casting news
for me like Black Panther was one that
was a for the most part of an exception
to this rule because most of the
performers that we got excited about got
something to do where they really got to
shine tonight gora Woodson Duke Lupita
Nyong'o a lot of the people involved
Jerry Daniel Kuya you know like they all
got to serve a purpose and really do
something as opposed to yeah we got a
black actor here you know it was that
was really cool but something like this
like maybe they'll do something exciting
I doubt I feel like it's just another
veto like yeah we got her name in here
you know yeah I feel like just
eventually everybody's gonna be in the
MCU like everybody passed a certain
caliber is just gonna be a part of it
alright so the last story we have
bookmarked here a quiet place to is from
a couple days ago
ooh casting a John Krasinski's directing
this
Killian Murphy is joining Emily Blunt in
this sequel I hope this is not an April
Fool it would be a weird couple days
from Jeff Snyder
ah the in Snyder yeah I mean to me
that's pretty cool I just like Killian
Murphy in general I do - I love Killian
Murphy and favorites
I think him being it's like there's no
way to theorize what they're gonna do
he's gonna be like one of the aliens but
half-human and he's gonna unite the
races together he's gonna direct a
really awkward sex scene with Emily
Blunt Murphy it's all about emily
Blunt's character moving on and finding
love with a new mate it's gonna just be
getting off on this news and it's like -
it is yeah keep having sex throughout
the movie and then you know how scary
would that be like a combination sex
scene slash horror sequence yeah they
gotta hide but also keep you know doing
it these are the best theories we got
today people who grade-a theories man if
you want the top notch you come here and
Jenna yes of course we're excited for
the egg I'm not I'm not excited to wake
up early bf and am i jealous of Anthony
no now we'll have a Milly before too
long and then we'll be able to rub it in
his face I mean he like he see the part
of the chant a part of the big reason of
how he started the channel was
inspiration for me starting up one first
and you know and his content that he
primarily covers is different than what
I've ever really covers own know if we
were the exact same thing in the exact
same video a little time that I might be
more jealous but if anything I'm really
happy for him and I'm proud of him he's
come a long way he works his ass off and
he get works
he brings a like eight different girls a
week you know like five over there right
now it's crazy just shuffle samman now
he goes one in the closet pulls another
one out so many girls anyway guys yeah
this was it for the livestream thank you
guys for tuning in and thank you -
shouts out to everyone who pitched in
for the super chat here
Brittany lang
to Mystic em read 8jf Jenna Harry
you guys are awesome thank you so much
and appreciate so everyone who stuck
here the whole time all the peeps from
YouTube all the peeps from patreon
everybody who came in gonna be filming a
one-punch man reaction they'll go up
there and I just don't mention this to
you got an editor to come to do Game of
Thrones for us so that we get that up by
Monday after the Sunday when we film
them and you know like like I said in
this livestream rules get very frickin
strict for you know what gets blocked or
not so hopefully they don't get blocked
but it can least go up on YouTube I'm
gonna make 10-minute cuts and we'll do
stream along for our patreon page thank
you guys so much for being here fun to
start off the Monday hanging out with
y'all